what advice would you give to a young
person said your son today in high
school maybe even college about career
about life
this may be where i get into trouble a
little bit
we are coming to the end
we're we're rapidly entering a time
between worlds
so we have a world now that's starting
to really crumble under the weight of
aging institutions that no longer even
pretend to serve the purposes they're
created for we are creating technologies
that are hurtling billions of people
headlong into philosophical crises who
they don't even know the philosophical
operating systems in their firmware and
they're heading into a time when that
gets vaporized
so
for people in high school and certainly
i tell my son this as well he's in
middle school
people in college
you are going to have to find your own
way
you're going to have to have a pioneer
spirit even if you live
in the middle of the most dense urban
environment
all of human reality around you
is the result of the last few
generations of humans agreeing to play
certain kinds of games a lot of those
games no longer
no longer operate according to the rules
they used to
collapse is non-linear but it will be
managed and so if you are in a
particular social caste or economic cast
and it's it's not
um i think it's it's not kosher to say
that about america but america is a very
stratified and classist society
there's some mobility but but it's
really quite classist and in america
unless you're in the upper middle class
you are headed into very choppy waters
so it is really really good to think and
understand the fundamentals of what you
need to build a meaningful life
for you your loved ones with your family
and almost all of the technology being
created that's consumer facing
is designed to own people
to take the four stack you know of
people to delaminate them and to own
certain portions of that stack
and so if you want to be an integral
human being if you want to have your
agency and you want to find your own way
in the world you know when you're young
would be a great time to spend time
looking at
some of the classics around you know
what it means to live a good life what
it means to build connection with people
and so much of the status games so much
of the
stuff you know uh one of the things that
i sort of talked about as we create
more and more technology
there's a gradient technology and a
gradient technology always leads to a
gradient of power and this is
jacqueline's point to some extent as
well that gradient of power is not going
to go away the technologies are going so
fast
that even people like me who helped
create some of this stuff i'm being left
behind that's on the cutting edge
research i don't know what's going on in
gans today you know i go read some
proceedings so
as the world gets more more
technological it will create more more
gradients where people will see
power economic fortunes
and the way they make the people who are
left behind okay with their lot in life
is they create lottery systems
they make you
take part
in the narrative of your own being
trapped in your own
economic sort of zone
so avoiding those kinds of things
is really important knowing when someone
is running game on you basically
so these are the things i would tell
young people it's a dark message but
it's realism i mean it's what i see
so after you gave some realism you sit
back you sit back with your son you're
looking out of the sunset
what
to him
can you give as words of hope and to you
from where do you derive hope for the
future of our world so you said at the
individual level you have to have a
pioneer mindset to go back to the
classics to understand what is in human
nature you can find meaning but at the
societal level
what trajectory when you look at
possible trajectories what gives you
hope
what gives me hope is that
we have little
tremors now
shaking people out of the reverie of the
fiction of modernity that they've been
living in kind of a late 20th century
style modernity um
that's that's good i think
because um
and also to your point earlier we you
people are burning out on some of the
social media stuff they're sort of
seeing the ugly side especially the
latest news with uh facebook and the
whistleblower right it's quite clear
these things are not
all they're cracked up to be so do you
believe like i i believe better social
media can be built because they are
burning out and they'll incentivize
other competitors to be built do you
think that's possible well the thing
about it is that um when you have
extractive return on returns um
you know capital coming in and saying
look you own a network give me some
exponential dynamics out of this network
what are you going to do you're going to
just basically put a toll keeper at
every single node and every single
graph uh edge every node every vertex
every edge
um but if you don't have that need for
it if no one's sitting there saying hey
wikipedia monetize every every character
every byte every phrase
then generative human dynamics will
naturally sort of arise assuming we do
we respect a few principles around
online communications so the greatest
and biggest social network in the world
is still like email sms right yes so
we're fine there the issue with the
social media as we call it now is
they're all they're actually just new
amplification systems right now it's
benefit of certain people like yourself
who have interesting content um to to to
to be amplified um so it's created a
creator economy and that's that's cool
there's a lot of great content out there
but giving everyone a shot at the fame
lottery saying hey you could also have
your if you wiggle your butt the right
way on tick tock you could have your 15
seconds of micro fame that's not healthy
for society at large so i think if we
can create tools that help people
be
conscientious about their attention
spend time looking at the past and
really retrieving memory and culling not
calling but processing and thinking
about
that
i think that's certainly possible and
hopefully that's what we get
um so i'm sorry
the bigger picture the bigger question
about uh you're asking about what gives
me hope
is that
um these early shocks of you know
coveted lockdowns
and remote work and all these different
kinds of things i think it's getting
people to
a point where
they are look they're they're sort of
no longer in the reverie right as my
friend jim rutz says there's more people
with ears to hear now right with
pandemic
and education everyone's like wait wait
what have you guys been doing with my
kids like how are you teaching them that
what is this crap you're giving them as
homework right so i think these are the
kinds of things that are getting
um in the supply chain disruptions
getting more people to think about how
do we actually just make stuff
this is all good
but the concern is that
it's still going to take a while
for these things for people to learn how
to be agentic again
um
and to be in right relationship with
each other and with the world
so the the message of hope is still
people are resilient and we're build we
are building some really amazing
technology and i also like to me i
derive a lot of hope from
from individuals in that van
mm-hmm the power of a single individual
to uh transform the world to do positive
things to the world is quite incredible
now you've been talking about it's nice
to have as many of those individuals as
possible right but even the power of one
is kind of magical
it is it is we're in a mode now where we
can do that i think also you know part
of what i try to do is in coming to
podcasts like yours and then you know
spamming with all this philosophical
stuff that i've got going on
um there are a lot of good people out
there trying to put um words around the
current technological social
economic crises that we're facing
in the space of a few short years i
think there has been a lot of great
content produced around this stuff for
people who want to see
want to find out more or think more
about this we're popularizing certain
kinds of philosophical ideas that
move people beyond just the oh you're
communist oh your capitalist kind of
stuff like it's sort of we're way past
that now
so that also gives me hope that i feel
like i myself am getting a handle on how
to think about these things
it makes me feel like i can you know
hopefully affect
change for the better
you